moi j'ai toujours rêvé d'aller dans le
futur voir ce que ça donne tu sais dans
ma tête il est stylé comme dans la
course de demain
alors qu'en fait il sera peut-être juste
comme ça
ce que tu peux alors j'étais là avant
allez tire toi tu tire toi on va tous
c'est bon tu m'a saoulé la nulle son
futur
le cinéma aussi ça va être quoi avant il
y avait là deux dès maintenant et la 3d
bientôt qu alassane d
bon hureau et la mode par exemple dans
le futur les fringues avoir semblé à
quoi
en cause les mots changent aussi les
jeunes dans le futur y parlerons pas
comme nous le langage ça va donner quoi
non mais attends maman c'est bon quoi
attends mais hugo lui non messieurs avec
ma mère m6 vers soul c'est mon cas déjà
hier j'étais avec steve on a soumises
sur l'une tradex c'était méga show ans
voir ben j'en doute pas et en plus y
aller avec cette superbe ace mais
j'avais jamais remarqué elle est
vachement flow oui donc ça veut rien
dire flowing exact mais ça fait
futuriste ouais avant les téléphones ça
servait juste à téléphoner maintenant ça
sert à plein de choses mais dans le
futur ils vont faire encore plus de
trucs vendée des habits de marne
tiens regardez j'ai téléchargé
l'application pizza 1 tu cliques de
chute à une pizza bien que de la pète la
whey parce que c'est une version
gratuite
selon la pâte j'aime bien manger des
croûtes ok les relations amoureuses
aussi ont changé avec la technologie
avant c'était comme ça ma douce je vous
croise depuis maintenant onze ans sans
jamais vous parlez pensez-vous chez
testing que nous pourrions désormais
nous dire bonjour
et qui sait peut-être que dans quelques
années nous pourrions aller au ballon
sans théine charge maintenant c'est
comme ça
salut est dans le futur ça va être
commandés au marché des barges mais
parce que plus ils galèrent à 99% de
compatibilité je réponds oui à manger
trop contente et très lourde et la vie
tu t'appelles comment il s'appelle aux
ruines ouais c'est pourri mais on à 99%
de compatibilité c'est hyper rare je
t'aime moi aussi j'en saurai plus la
science aura fait des avancées de ouf
c'est sur moi par exemple j'ai pas de
mémoire
j'espère qu'ils vont me trouver un truc
et hugo ça va ah oui oui
faits et parce que clémentine clémentine
si ouais je
si tu veux avoir un futur de ouf
un truc de dingue un truc n'est pas bien
tu vas voir la bande-annonce à la
poursuite de demain et pour encore plus
de futurs abonne toi